How was your first futsal
? It's fun. Would you like to join the club?
Excuse me, but from
5,000 yen,
could you please put the fixed amount in this envelope next time
?  I understand that, but it
takes more money to collect the necessary coins.
Yes, withdrawing money from an ATM costs 200 yen.
If you do that, it
won't cost you money, but things at
convenience stores are expensive, so you
'll have to pay.  I'm
sorry I bought all the ingredients online. I'm going to
donate the remaining 11 yen. No, I
can't burden the customer.  I don't
think the people at the convenience store think you're a
pervert. Did you
say something? It
's nothing.  Well, if you do this, you'll get your coins back, but it's
much cheaper to buy it online.